MY NEXT GUEST HAS BEEN IN EXILE
SINCE LAST YEAR.
THIS IS VLADIMIR MILOV.
HE IS A VOCAL CRITIC OF PUTIN.
HE IS JOINING ME NOW FROM
LITHUANIA.
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM IN A.
YOU CAN SEE AND HEAR THESE
REPORTS AND PRISONER EXCHANGES.
YOU ALSO KNOW THAT SO MANY
RUSSIANS ARE FLEEING PUTIN'S
WAR.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE FACT
THAT THE RUSSIANS ARE DOING
THAT?
DO YOU THINK WILL AFFECT THE
COURSE OF THE WAR OR VLADIMIR
PUTIN AT ALL?
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE.
I HAVE TO BEGAN WITH SAYING
THAT MOST GREAT MAJORITIES OF
RUSSIAN PEOPLE HAVE NEVER
EXPECTED ANY OF THIS.
MY COUNTRY WILL BE INVOLVED IN
SUCH A HORRIFIC GENOCIDAL AND
BARBARIC AGGRESSION AGAINST
UKRAINE.
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE AGAINST IT.
THEY WILL SPEAK UP.
SOME OF THEM ARE FLEEING.
MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
THEY ARE AFRAID OF BEING
MOBILIZED TO THE BATTLE LINES.
THERE ARE MANY MORE FORCED TO
STAY BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOWHERE
TO GO.
MANY OF THEM JUST DON'T HAVE AN
INTERNATIONAL PASSPORT TO BEGIN
WITH.
I JUST WANT TO STRESS HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS AND WHAT
HORRIBLE CONDITIONS THEY ARE
FACING INSIDE OF THIS
TOTALITARIAN REGIME.
IT IS THREATENING THEM WITH
REAL PRISON TERMS FROM
THREATENING AGAINST THE WAR.
>> WE SAID THAT YOU LAUGHED
AROUND 2021.
WHY DID YOU LEAVE?
EXPLAIN THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHAT TOOK YOU FROM BEING A
DEPUTY ENERGY MINISTER, IN THE
INNER CIRCLE, YOU WENT TO BEING
AN OPPONENT, A CRITIC, AND
SOMEBODY WHO IS NOW WILLING TO
LIVE IN EXILE?
>> I LEFT THE GOVERNMENT 20
YEARS AGO.
I'VE BEEN IN VOCAL OPPOSITION
SINCE THEN.
I USED TO WORK WITH BORIS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, I VOTED
AGAINST THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION BACK IN 2000.
I WAS THE GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL.
THAT WAS POSSIBLE AT THE TIME.
IT WAS A RELATIVELY FREE
COUNTRY.
MADE ME LEAVE?
THERE WAS THE STORY WENT AND
ALEXEI NAVALNY RETURNED.
PEOPLE WERE STAGING MAJOR
PROTESTS.
I HAD ABOUT 20 POLICEMEN AT MY
DOORSTEP WAITING FOR ME TO GET
ARRESTED.
I QUICKLY UNDERSTOOD THAT IF I
DID NOT LEAVE THE COUNTRY THAT
I WOULD END UP IN JAIL.
JUST LIKE ALEXEI NAVALNY.
JUST LIKE VLADIMIR --
THOSE WERE MY FELLOW COMRADES.
MANY OF US HAVE CHOSEN THAT.
THAT IS THE MESSAGE FROM
ALEXEI.
WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE TO
CONTINUE THE POSITIVE WEIRD.
WE SERVE SOME TIME IN JAIL
ALREADY.
WE WILL YET HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN.
RIGHT NOW, IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
MANY PROMINENT OPPOSITION
NERVES ARE STAYING FREEING
CONTINUING TO WORK WE ARE
FORECASTING --
WE ARE SPREADING THE MESSAGE OF
FREEDOM, SPREADING THE MESSAGE
OF SUPPORTING UKRAINE AND
ENDING THIS HORRIFIC WAR.
>> ON THAT LEVEL, I THEN WANT
TO ASK YOU ABOUT TV RAIN.
>> THIS WAS ONE OF THE VERY FEW
INDEPENDENT RUSSIAN OUTLETS.
IT WAS TRYING TO TELL THE TRUTH.
THEY LEFT AFTER THE WAR.
THEY SET UP SHOP IN LATVIA.
NOW, JUST RECENTLY, THIS WAS
OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS, THEIR
LICENSE HAS BEEN REVOKED BY
THAT COUNTRY.
UKRAINE AND LATVIA HAVE SORT OF
SUGGESTED THAT THEY ARE WORKING
TO FURTHER THE RUSSIAN WAR
PROPAGANDA.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
I HAVE SPOKEN TO THE PEOPLE
THAT RUN TV RAIN.
THEY DID NOT WANT TO PROMOTE
ANY RUSSIAN WAR AIMS.
>> NO.
THEY DO NOT DO THIS AT ALL.
THEY ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
INDEPENDENT MEDIA OUTLET.
THEY OPERATE --
THEIR AUDIENCE IN RUSSIA'S
DOZENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
CONTINUOUSLY SPREAD'S
ANTI-PUTIN IN ANTI WAR MESSAGES
THAT.
THAT IS WHAT WE NEED RIGHT NOW.
LISTEN, AND I WANT TO REFER TO
VERY RECENTLY ISSUED STATEMENTS.
I --
THEY WANT RAT LATVIA TO
IMMEDIATELY REVOKED DECISION ON
SUSPENDING THIS COMPANY'S
LICENSE.
THEY CALL IT DISPROPORTIONATE.
THEY DID NOT REALLY CONSIDER
THE CONTEXT OF WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
I CAN EXPLAIN THIS.
IT IS VERY SIMPLE.
IN LATVIA, THERE ARE PERPETUAL
TENSIONS BETWEEN --
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT LOCAL
RUSSIAN POPULATION AND SOME
LATVIAN'S.
PART OF THEM HAPPENED TO BE PRO
PUTIN.
THAT PERPETUAL CONFLICT SPARKS
--
THEY ARE ARRIVING.
THEY ARE SAYING SOME
UNFORTUNATE THINGS IN DOING
SOME LET THE LATVIAN RESPONSE
WAS DISPROPORTIONATE --
.
I WOULD STICK TO THE POSITION
OF THE EUROPEAN FEDERATION OF
JOURNALISM.
MANY OF THEM SAY THAT TV RAIN
SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE.
>> WE HAVE SPOKEN IN THE PAST
TOO MANY BALTIC LEADERS.
THERE IS A FEAR OF SO-CALLED
FIFTH COLUMN.
.
IT WILL BE THREATENING A
NATIONAL SECURITY.
SO DOES UKRAINE SOME PEOPLE
HAVE SAID, YOU KNOW, RUSSIANS
ARE CARROT-Y MAYBE INFILTRATING
THE DEFECTORS.
TRYING TO COME AND MAKE TROUBLE
IN THESE PLACES.
THEY HAVE SIZEABLE
RUSSIAN-SPEAKING AND RUSSIAN
LEANING MINORITIES.
THIS IS WHAT THE ESTONIAN PRIME
MINISTER TOLD US A FEW MONTHS
AGO.
>> THE RUSSIAN POPULATION IS
NOT A HOMOGENEOUS GROUP.
THEY HAD DIFFERENT WORRIES.
IN THE EASTERN PART OF ESTONIA,
THERE ARE ALSO PEOPLE WHO ARE
MORE IN THE PROPAGANDA SPHERE
OF RUSSIA.
THEY ARE HEARING THESE
NARRATIVES THAT RUSSIA IS
PRESENTING.
WE ARE WORKING ON KEEPING OUR
SOCIETY TOGETHER WELL WE HAVE
DIFFERENT VIEWS OF OUR PAST.
WE HAVE A COMMON FUTURE.
>> I HEARD WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
THEM.
THEY SHOULD TAKE THE EUROPEAN
REPORT ABOUT THIS.
DO YOU NOT THINK THAT SHUTTING
DOWN --
VISIT HELPED RUSSIA RATHER THAN
HEARD IT?
>> THIS IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT IS A LEGITIMATE SECURITY
CONCERN.
MANY RUSSIANS ARE COMING IN.
SOME OF THEM PROBABLY SPREADING
MESSAGES THAT HELP PUTIN LISTEN,
I THINK THAT SHUTTING THE DOOR,
CANCELING, REFUSING ALL
RUSSIANS INCLUDING DOZENS OF
MILLIONS OF PRO-DEMOCRACY
RUSSIANS, THAT IS THE WRONG
THING TO DO.
THIS IS HELPING PUTIN MORE THAN
DOING HIM HARM.
IT DEMORALIZE A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THEY LOOK AT EUROPE AS A BEACON
OF HOPE IN THIS AGE OF DARKNESS.
PUTIN'S SPOKESMAN, THEY WERE
ECSTATICALLY HAPPY ABOUT
SHUTTING DOWN TV RAIN.
THEY SAID, LISTEN, WHO TOLD YOU?
THIS IS NOT A REAL DEMOCRACY.
IT HAS CENSORSHIP.
THAT IS A VERY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE MOVE.
>> TO THAT POINT, I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE WHAT YOU JUST SAID.
PUTIN, HIS SPOKESMAN SAID THAT
IT ALWAYS SEEMS LIKE SOMEWHERE
IS BETTER THAN HOME.
THERE IS FREEDOM SOMEWHERE, BUT
AT HOME THERE IS NO FREEDOM.
THIS IS ONE OF THE CLEAREST
EXAMPLES THAT DEMONSTRATES THE
FALSITY OF SUCH ILLUSIONS.
IT IS INTERESTING THAT THESE
DECISIONS CAN HAVE THAT KIND OF
BACKLASH REACTION.
AND I WANT TO ASK YOU TO TURN
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE SANCTIONS.
PUTIN HAS SAID A LOT ABOUT HOW
HIS ECONOMY IS FINE.
YES, THEY DO HAVE TO BE A BIT
MORE CAREFUL IN VIGILANT.
BUT THEY ARE REAPING THE
BENEFITS OF THE SKYROCKETING
OIL PRICES.
OTHERS SUGGEST THAT THE SINK
CHAINS ARE HURTING.
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO HERD.
CAN YOU TELL ME FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AS A FORMER
MINISTER AND WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING THERE, HOW DO YOU THINK
THIS IS AFFECTING THEM?
>> AS A MATTER OF FACT --
THEY HAVE A DEVASTATING IMPACT.
THEY DEMANDED CONTRACTION.
IT IS EVERYWHERE.
WHEN PUTIN HAS BEEN ABLE TO
STAY AFLOAT.
I'M THERE IS A HUGE PILE OF
STATISTICS SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE WAR.
WE HAVE A VERY NARROW --
>> THERE IS THE EXCHANGE RATE.
--
IF YOU LOOK AT UNEMPLOYMENT, IT
IS LOWEST ON RECORD.
THERE ARE 5 MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT IS ACCORDING TO OFFICIAL
CONSISTENT STATISTICS.
THERE ARE HIDDEN FORMS OF
EMPLOYMENT.
YOU CAN SEE MAJOR ECONOMIC
ATTRACTIONS.
THAT IS SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
THAN THE OFFICIAL NUMBERS THAT
ARE STATED BY THE RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA.